I adore the show you know I grew up my
mother loved the film growing up I loved
the film when she showed it to me so
obviously this show means a lot to me
um and obviously it means a lot to so
many people you know we're coming back
into a world that so many people have so
much Nostalgia for so in terms of both
production and writing when you're
dealing with these Legacy characters so
Willow sorsha particularly the legacy of
mad Mart again especially the way that
you handle it in the show what was it
like sort of figuring out how to handle
that were there nerves involved or was
it you know let's just tell the best
story that we possibly can it's
interesting because it isn't until you
this question right now and the the very
eloquent way you phrased it that uh that
it clarifies for me is that the truth of
it is it's actually a great gift it's a
huge benefit to have these characters
and these sort of Legends built into the
story you're telling because with a
fresh piece of material you don't have
anything to base it on you have to sort
of give them everything Warrick comes
into Willow with so much credibility
that you can't yeah it's it's an
invaluable resource more than any the
effect could ever be is simply seeing
him standing there on a mountain holding
a staff you know where you are and and
same frankly with Matt martigan it's
like that we were going to tell this
story where his children were going to
be so at the center of it you really
need to to have some place to go with a
a larger than life Legend and even
really from its Inception mad Morgan was
always going to be a question at the
center of the show we were gonna make
you know and and where he went and how
his legacy sort of created these two
children felt inherent in what we were
gonna do the bar is so high as well when
you have those kinds of characters like
Willow like mad martigan sorcia it's
just then it creates that challenge of
okay we're introducing new characters
and they have to you know meet meet that
that very high bar that's been set and
we I have to say we feel very lucky that
our cast is so incredible and embody
these new characters beautifully they
are just instantly delightful fun very
modern and it does feel like you know to
be able to have done both to to have the
Legacy characters as John says and
introduce new characters that you
immediately bond with that that is the
you know that is the best you can hope
for and I will say I adore all of the
new characters that have come into this
and I've seen them I I see so much of
Matt martigan and sorcia in kit and Eric
and just watching that made me so happy
and I told them that but in terms of you
have so many care characters was it a
struggle to sort of balance you know
everybody getting their due time on
screen or did it just kind of when
people came together it was natural
right the answer it's interesting
because I I imagine though I couldn't
say with any ex from any experience that
it's much harder on other shows where
the characters are all separated with
this story where they're all sort of
united in a quest by the middle of the
first episode what you get is that that
feeling that you know I grew up with a
with a father who loved writing
ensembles of dinner table scenes and
people together and that's great fun and
it keeps the story very focused on what
they're after and what they want you
know the magic of them together is for
me my you know my favorite thing about
the show and funny enough being here in
London right now yeah I find that every
time I'm in London I tend to watch
Friends yeah because it seems to be on
all the time and I adore it and I fall
right back into it and as I was watching
it again this time I mean it reminded me
just the warm feelings you have of being
part of this group that you just love
the feeling of hanging out with you see
a version of yourself within all of them
they feel so at home and the the
chemistry with them together is so
delightful to to me you know this group
of this new group of unlikely friends
and you know last night on this
adventure that is my absolute favorite
thing about the show no last night we we
screened the show for for some people
here in England and and afterwards we
were out and the the girls were together
and Michelle snapped a picture of of
Aaron and Ruby and Ellie and it's
exactly like the show the camaraderie
that exists between them is that
authentic and real and I I hope it comes
off on the screen because it's all love
it absolutely does and I think the thing
that this show sort of also carries with
it is the the idea of Hope and
perseverance that the the original film
carries with it is there anything else
that you hope people people take away
from this show yeah I mean I think that
what's interesting about television
versus a movie is that a movie is such a
tight a lean bit of a ride you know it's
a rush it's a hit of the gas with the
show you've got eight hours and you
really have an opportunity to build out
these characters in ways that movies
simply don't allow and what we wanted
and what I think we've gotten to is is a
layer of complexity and conflict in each
of these people that is really honest
and and relatable they're all sort of
wrestling with what they want and what's
expected of them you know and and trying
to figure out how to navigate those
polls over what we hope will be a long
story I think it also continues what was
so thematically
strong about that original film which is
that Heroes can come from anywhere you
know it really is about your character
about courage about being selfless make
being brave above anything and all of
our new characters have to face those
same tests and by the end of the season
you know the hope is that you leave with
those feelings those aspirational ideas
and and you want to see them again which
we we sure do we do absolutely well
congratulations on the show it's
wonderful and thank you so much for
talking to me it's great talking to you